أعتقد أن التفوق الجوي الأجنبي [الموسيقى] ضروري
لأوكرانيا في المستقبل لتكون قادرة على
ردع روسيا عن محاولة هذا
مرة أخرى ولدينا القدرة التي
بدأنا العمل عليها الآن من خلال
تدريب الطيارين الأوكرانيين على F-16
ستضيف بالطبع إلى
قوة القوات الجوية الأوكرانية بشكل كبير في
المستقبل
الطيران الحكيم تقنيًا جيدًا ، أعني إذا
كنت طيارًا فهذه أيضًا مجرد
طائرة ولكن تطير طائرة مقاتلة
وتنتقل إلى طائرة F-16  قد
تعني مثل
مفاهيم تصميم مختلفة تقنية مختلفة أحد
الأشياء التي تختلف في معظم
الطائرات الغربية هو أننا نطلق عليها ما
يسمى بالأيدي على دواسة الوقود والعصا
وهذا يعني أنه على دواسة الوقود
التي تستخدمها للتسريع وعلى
التمسك بالتحكم في الطائرة ، فهناك
الكثير من الأزرار التي تستخدمها لتشغيل
جميع إلكترونيات الطيران وعادة ما تكون في
المعدات السوفيتية غير موجودة أو على الأقل
جزء من التصميم ، لذلك نحتاج فقط إلى
العمل معهم والتعلم على سبيل المثال
من شريك  مثل بولندا التي
تحولت أيضًا من MiG-29 إلى F-16
وتعلم من دروسها في هذا
الانتقال مثل ما يتطلبه الأمر حقًا من
الأجانب